- [Mark] Craig?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Where you from, originally?
- Cerritos.
- [Mark] Cerritos, and how
long you been here on Skid Row?
- [Craig] Since 2000.
- [Mark] Since 2000. What happened to you,
that you ended up down here?
- [Craig] Just too lazy,
didn't want to work.
- [Mark] You just didn't
feel like working?
- [Craig] Yeah.
- [Mark] So, living down here,
there's no responsibility.
- Yes.
- [Mark] No hassles?
- No hassles.
- [Mark] Very simple?
- Very simple.
- [Mark] You go to the
mission to get your dinner?
- Yes I do.
- [Mark] And breakfast, probably?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How about lunch?
- You know, I eat on the, on the road.
- [Mark] Yeah. Do you panhandle?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And what about drugs?
Do you do any of the
drugs that are down here?
- Weed and drink beer.
- [Mark] That's it?
That's nothing compared to
what else goes on around here.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then, now,
where do you sleep?
- Anywhere on the streets.
- [Mark] Wherever you can?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- 49.
- [Mark] 49.
And tell me about your childhood.
- I just grew up in a good
house, in a household.
My parents, they worked.
- [Mark] No abuse?
- No abuse, no drugs.
- [Mark] No nothing?
- Just work.
- [Mark] You just don't feel like
taking on the responsibility?
- Yeah, work.
- [Mark] Of life and
work, and having a job and
paying bills and all that?
Do you think you're happy?
Do you feel like you're happy this way?
- Yes, I do.
- [Mark] Yeah. You seem pretty content.
And where would you like to
see yourself in five years?
- I couldn't tell you.
Just have my life-
Not necessarily in an
apartment or anything.
Just...
doing right.
- [Mark] And did you feel like you're
not doing right, right now?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What's what's going on now?
- Oh, just like my clothes are dirty.
No shower.
Just doing right.
- [Mark] Yeah, but that's easy to fix.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Mark] Excellent, do
you have any other family?
Are your parents still around?
- No, no.
- [Mark] So it's just you?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Were you an only child?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Okay.
And, do you have any girlfriends,
or plan on, have no kids?
- No, no.
- [Mark] Okay, do you ever
have, or anything like that?
- No.
- [Mark] You've never had
relationships? Never had any?
- I've had one relationship with Laurie,
and it was a good one
and it lasted for like couple years.
And we went by our separate way.
I still talk to her, she's good.
She's a nice person.
She's just not really my type.
She's sort of fat.
Whether or not, we alright.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- [Craig] No- Yeah, yeah I got friends.
I got a lot of associates,
I call them associates.
- [Mark] People that you
see a lot on the street?
- [Craig] Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] But they're not
really like tight friends?
- [Craig] No.
- [Mark] And your health
is good? You feel fine?
- [Craig] Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And you say drinking, weed,
you don't get out of
control with that or you do?
- [Craig] Actually I don't. No.
- [Mark] You're just avoiding
all the stress of life.
- [Craig] Yeah.
(laughter)
- [Mark] You picked the right
city to do that in, LA's warm.
You've seen some crazy stuff
down here in Skid Row, right?
- [Craig] Actually, I haven't.
I've heard about it,
but I haven't seen it.
- [Mark] So you tend
to stay away from the-
- [Craig] Drama?
- [Mark] The drama.
- [Craig] Yes.
- [Mark] Yeah, so you're
sleeping somewhere
closer to downtown or federal buildings...
- [Craig] Yeah, to missions.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- I sleep closer to the missions.
- [Mark] Oh, I see. Okay, cool.
- It's safe.
- [Mark] Well thank you for talking to me.
- [Craig] Yeah.
- [Mark] I appreciate it.
Be safe out there.
- [Craig] I will.
- Hey, if I tell you a funny
joke, can I earn another 20?
If I tell you a funny joke?
Help me out, I need
another 20, help me out.
(laughter)
- [Mark] I'll tell you
what, if you make me laugh,
I'll give you another 20.
- Alright.
- [Mark] No, no stay put.
- Can you hear this? Say, "No."
Say "No."
- [Mark] No.
- Let me turn it up for you.
(laughter)
- [Mark] Alright, you're good.
- Thank you, I can walk from here.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.